The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
ROSS COLLINS: Welcome
to the tutorial
on the method of
simulated moments.
Collaborating together
on this tutorial
is Armin Ashoury, Ross
Collins, and Ali Kamil.
We will present the
tutorial in two parts.
The first part, presented
by me, Ross Collins,
is an overview of the MSM, why
it's useful, and how it works.
The second part, presented
by Armin Ashoury,
will go through
the details of how
to implement the
MSM in Vensim DSS.
Background
information on the MSM
is included in the associated
book chapter with this video.
The chapter goes into much more
mathematical detail in the MSM
formulation, which the
interested viewer should
consult if looking
for more information.
In this video, we do not dissect
every individual formula,
but instead try to give a
useful overview of the MSM,
and then apply it
to a simple example.
The step-by-step
replication the tutorial
will likely require reading and
understanding the book chapter
in more detail.
Still, this video
should give a flavor
of why MSM is useful, how it
works in the general level,
and what sort of time and effort
is required to implement it
in system dynamics models.
So what does the MSM let you do?
Well, according
to this quote, it
allows one to "compare
time series data
against the same
variables in a model,
and minimize the weighted sum
of a function of the error term
by changing the uncertain
parameters until best
fitting estimates are found
through optimization,"
This is important
for model validation.
So specifically
what MSM does is it
compares the
moments of real data
against the moments
of simulated data
or just the model output
from a simulation.
So moments are things like
mean, variance, skewness.
Kurtosis is another one.
These are the first, second,
third, and fourth moments
respectively.
An important thing to realize
is that unknown parameters
in a model will alter
the simulated moments.
So if you have some unknown
parameters, x, and some moment,
y, if you change x,
then y will change.
So what the optimization method
does-- referred to in the quote
up at the top-- is
it will find values
for our unknown
parameters that minimize
the weighted
difference-- and I'll
get to why weighted is important
later-- the weighted difference
between real and
simulated moments.
And these weighted differences
are called the error terms.
So we're going to apply this
MSM to a simple obesity model.
We basically have
weight data in Excel--
this Excel file is included
with this video-- we have
weight data for a population
of 1,000 individuals at five
different points in
time, specifically
years 1, 5, 10, 15, and 20.
The moment conditions we use
are mean and standard deviation.
And given that we have five
years of data and two moments,
we have 10 moments in total.
So the unknown
parameters that we're
trying to estimate
through the MSM technique
are called Overfeeding,
Starvation,
and Energy Intake Extra Trend.
So I am going to show
this model really quick.
It's a very simple
model that tracks
the weight gain of
1,000 individuals.
You can see you have the
stock structure here,
an array of 1,000 people, so
we're utilizing subscripts
to denote these
1,000 individuals.
And the major feedback is
that as weight change accrues,
you have some energy intake
balance that changes.
This feeds back into
one's energy intake
through the starvation
and overfeed parameters
and then alters
the weight change.
So the three uncertain
parameters are here.
We have an underlying
trend in energy intake
that impacts the weight
trajectory of each individual.
And then we have the starvation
and overfeed parameters
that impact this major feedback.
If energy intake balance
is on the heavier side,
starvation kicks in with
some parameter of force.
From the lower side,
the overfeed parameter
kicks in with some
amount of force.
So let's see.
If we click on the weight
here and show a graph,
we're only going to get to
show 16 of the individuals,
but you can see the
trajectory of them
through time--
over the 20 years.
The initial conditions
are captured here.
The mean of individuals
is 80 kilograms--
so you can see it sort
of circled around there--
and the standard deviation
is 5 kilograms, which
is why the initial
conditions differ.
But you can see
the trajectories,
and we have this for
1,000 individuals.
So then the idea of the
MSM is you have these 1,000
trajectories, and you
have the moments that
define these trajectories.
And we compare that
against the real data
that we have in the exercise.
So let's see.
Final slide that I'm
going to talk about
before I hand it off to
Armin to go into the Vensim
implementation.
So basically, there are
four overarching steps
and four Vensim models
associated to each step.
So in the first step, we are
basically making the first cut
at estimating these
three unknown parameters.
And to do that,
we need-- and I'm
going to pull up the
book chapter here--
we need to minimize the
weighted differences
of these parameters.
And that's what you can see here
in equation three in the book
chapter.
This theta hat is the set
of parameters-- in our case
just three-- and
we want to minimize
the difference between simulated
moments and the real moments
to use for data.
And we have here in
the middle this W,
which is a weighting matrix.
And the purpose of
the weighting matrix
is to give less weight to really
noisy and uncertain moments,
since those are going to sort
of hijacked the optimization
process when trying
to choose parameters.
So the first W that we
use in the first step
is essentially just taking
the real data moments
and squaring them and then
taking the reciprocal.
And those are along the
diagonal elements of W. Armin
will go into more
detail about that,
but that's our initial
starting point for W.
So the output of that are
an initial set of parameter
estimates, not
necessarily optimized,
but certainly informed by
this initial weighting matrix.
The second step is to calculate
essentially a more efficiently
weighted W, or what we call W*,
and it uses an algorithm that
is discussed in the chapter.
It's equation four down here.
As you can see, it's reasonably
complicated and requires first
calculating the
variance-covariance matrix
of the simulated moments, which
again we can do in Vensim--
even though it's
easier in MATLAB--
and W* is simply the
inverse of this matrix.
So once we've got W*, we
basically go into the second
step, which is very
similar to the first step.
It's an optimization
yet again, but now we
have a more
efficiently weighted W.
And that gives us a better
set of optimized parameters.
The important thing
to note is that we
can iterate if we
are not happy with W,
but the final step involves
calculating competence
intervals for each of
our uncertain parameters.
Again, in our case,
we have three of them.
So these confidence
intervals are just
like other confidence intervals
and statistical exercises.
We want those bounds to
be as tight as possible,
and we don't want
them to include zero.
So that is the
overview of the MSM.
I'm going to hand
it off now to Armin,
who is going to go through
the major steps actually
implemented in Vensim.
So thank you for listening.
ARMIN ASHOURY: In
each model, we have
a part that captured the moments
we need for the MSM process.
So here, for example,
in the FirstStep model,
we see that we have the
main model of obesity.
And here we have
the part that tries
to capture the different
moments that we have.
For example, here we want to
catch the mean of body weights
and also similar
deviation of body weights.
Simply, this part tries to
create a matrix of moments.
For each column, we
have one simulation.
So here, for example, we
have like 10 simulations.
And for each row, we have
one of our moments here.
Since we have like five years of
data, which are year 1, 5, 10,
15, and 20, we have to
use two moments, which
are mean and standard deviation.
We have like 10 rows that,
for the first five years,
we have first five rows, we
have the mean of our years.
And for the second five rows,
we have a standard deviation
of our years.
So we can create this matrix
in whatever way you want,
but here we try to
capture these moments
and create that matrix
using second flow system.
In the FirstStep
of moment, we tried
to find three unknown parameters
of obesity model, which
are extra trends,
starvation, overfeed.
We use formula five
in the book chapter
and try to optimize
those parameters
based on that formula.
So here in formula five, you
see like different parameters
we have.
For example, M of s is the
average simulated vector
of moments.
So for example,
in our example, we
have like 10 simulation for
each one of those moments,
so we average the moments
over those simulation
and create a vector,
which is M of s here.
And M of d is the real
moments values in that vector
that we capture from
the real data we have.
W here is the initial
value for the weights.
For the initial value,
we use the Formula One
over moments, real
moments, to power of two.
In the model, we
call the function--
a function here
as the error term.
So here in the view 2
of our FirstStep model,
we can see that we have our
three unknown parameters here.
We put them all together
in one vector here
called parameter so that we
can deal with them easily.
So from the obesity
model, we get the moments
that we need here.
So if you take a look at the
moments here-- the moments
we have here-- in
the last year-- year
20-- you'll see that
we have matrices that
has 10 moments in it,
and for each moments
we have like 10 simulations.
So we have 10 in 10
matrix for each moments
in each simulation.
So we get those values.
And here we can get an average
over those 10 simulations,
and we create the M of s
that we talked about here.
So using that and
using the real data
that we have we calculate the
difference between the moment--
the selected moments
and the real moments.
And here, we see that
we calculate the W
based on the formula we have
for the initial value, which
is one over real moments
to the power of 2.
And using these data, we
calculate the error terms here,
which we just calculated
for the last time
of the simulation,
which is the year 20.
So as you can see
here, this formula
here is a formula 5 from the
chapter books that we have.
And finally, we have
to do some optimization
on the model to get the value.
So here, you'll see that we
want to optimize over the error
terms, and we want
to minimize it.
So we put error term
here on base minus one.
You have to do to choose a
policy for this optimization.
So we are what we want to
optimize over the parameters,
so we have to choose
the parameters
as the variable we
want to optimize.
And then we do the
optimization and you
will get the values we need.
So we do optimization, and
it may take for awhile, maybe
like 20 or 30 minutes.
So we are fast
forwarding to the values
we have at the end of that.
So as you can see
here, we have optimized
parameters-- optimized values
for our parameters, which
are kind of close to the
real values that we have.
So in the next model,
which is the CalcW model,
we try to calculate
the weight we
need for the MSM process
using other models.
So here we import optimized,
unknown parameters
from the previous model,
which is the FirstStep model,
to CalcW model.
Then we calculate
a variable called
S using the formula
for in the book chapter
that you can see it over here.
And the inverse
of that S variable
is the weight that we
need for our MSM process.
In the first view of
CalcW, although everything
is the same as this previous
model, in the second view,
we try to calculate the
S based on the formula we
have in the book chapter.
So here we can see that
we try to calculate
the average of
simulated moments.
And this is exactly the
same as the previous model,
and we try to
calculate the average
of each moment over
10 simulations.
And after that, you can
see that that average
of simulated moments
here in the formula 4.
And we have to subtract
the real value of moments
from that average and then
multiply to its transpose
and get another
average over that.
So here in the moments
differences variable,
we try to calculate
the formula we
have in the book
chapter formula 4.
And using that, we just
calculated the S hat
for the last final
time of simulation.
We only need to calculate the
value of S just for one time,
so that by inversing the
value of the matrix S,
we can get the value of matrix
W that we need the MSM process.
So we just want the
models for one time.
And here, after the
simulation ends,
you can see the
value of S hat we
need in the final time
of simulation here.
So we have like 10 by 10
matrix that has like difference
moments, and we have
to inverse this matrix
to get the real weight
matrix that we need.
In the next model, which
is the SecondStep model,
we again want to find
all known parameters
that we have using some
optimization this time
using the calculated w from
the previous part in the CalcW
part.
So we imported S matrix
from the previous part.
And by inversing that S matrix,
we get the W that we need.
And also, we can import
optimized parameters
from the FirstStep
model, or we can just
use some random other
variables, values
as the initial values
of the parameters.
And so finally, we do
another optimization
to find our three
unknown parameters.
And we again use
the formula (5).
Just this time, we
have the W calculated
from the previous model,
which was the CalcW model.
So here in the SecondStep
model, in view one,
you can see everything's
the same as the two
previous models.
And in view two,
you can see the only
[? serious ?] thing, that
difference from the FirstStep
model, is that we
import the value of S
and then inverse it to calculate
the W instead of calculating
W based on the data
moments that we have.
Here we have some kind
of [? bargain ?] Vensim.
And if you try to import the
values of S hat from previous
model using some
kind of function,
like GET VDF CONSTANT or any
other function that tries
to import the values
from the previous model,
then my Vensim cannot calculate
the inverse of that metrics
[INAUDIBLE].
So here we just copy-pasted
the values of the calculated S
matrix from previous
model and just put it here
as the exogenous
variable, and here we
calculate the
inverse of my matrix,
instead of just using
the imported values
from the previous model.
For the SecondStep
model, again, we
have to optimize the parameter.
So again, we have like the same
system as the FirstStep model.
We tried to minimize
the errors terms,
and we are trying to
optimize the parameters.
And after like the
simulation-- simulation may
take like an hour or so-- so
after the simulation ends,
we have optimized value
for our unknown parameters.
After the optimization
is finished,
we can see the optimized
parameters value here.
So we get these values for
each one of these parameters.
And we can see, for example,
0.002 is for [INAUDIBLE]
random, 0.35 is for
starvation, and 0.13
is for an overfeed
parameters here,
The next model, which is the
Confidence Interval Model,
we try to calculate
the confidence
interval of our
unknown parameters.
So here we need to import
the optimized parameters
from the SecondStep model and
the W from the CalcW model.
And then we calculate the
confidence intervals first
by calculating a
variable called Q.
We can see the formula for
calculating the Q here.
And then using that
Q, we calculate
the confidence interval using
this formula we can see here.
We just have to add and increase
our values from each parameter.
So here the confidence level
factor, for example for 95%,
the confidence
interval-- assuming
we have normal
distribution-- is 1.96.
Then we have to multiply that
value, that confidence level
factor to a square root of
q, and adding and subtracting
from the parameters.
So after that, we have
the confidence interval
for each one of our parameters.
So here in the Confidence
Interval Model,
we can see that
again we calculate
the average simulated
moment, and we
get the S from
the previous part.
Also, we have two import the
value of parameters meters
from the previous model, which
was the SecondStep model.
So we get the optimized
parameters here.
We get the value of S here.
And here we try to calculate
the confidence interval
using the formula that we have.
So here in the
formula 7, you can
see that we have 1 plus 1/K. K
here is number of simulation.
So for example, we
have 10 simulation.
Then we have delta as
minus 1, which is the W.
And again, delta--
delta here is the change
in moments of a
parameter by changing
the parameter for epsilon or
[? theta ?] [INAUDIBLE] value.
So for example, if you add
0.001 to an optimized value
of "Starvation", how much
it's average simulated mean
may change or standard deviation
may change to two moments
that we have.
So we tried to calculate
that delta here using
some [INAUDIBLE] variable.
In [INAUDIBLE] variable,
we just add and decrease
a value of epsilon
to each parameters,
and then we get the delta here.
Using this system
that you can see here,
we calculate the confidence
interval we need.
So again, we need to run
the model only for one time.
Just by running the
model just for one time,
we can calculate the confidence
interval that we need.
So after running
the model, we can
see this we have the
confidence intervals for,
for example, upper
bound confidence
interval for each one
of the parameters here,
and the lower bound
of confidence interval
for each one of the parameters
that we have in here.
The base obesity
model and the moments,
the capturing moments
structure that we
have in all four models,
are kind of the same,
except for the last model,
which is the confidence interval
model.
We have to add one
other set of scripts
that is for
sensitivity analysis.
For each one of
the parameters, we
have one upper bound
and one lower bound,
so we have to add six
subscripts to the model.
And for each one
of the subscript,
we have to run a
simulation to, for example,
catch the upper bound
of one of the parameters
or catch the lower
bound of the parameters.
So you have to change
the model in a way
that it runs the simulation for
each one of those subscription.
But everything else is the
same in our four models
for the base of
the obesity model
and the moment capturing
model for a structure.
Finally, if we put aside
the [INAUDIBLE] in Vensim
and assume that we can
just import and export
[INAUDIBLE] between models and
calculate the inverse of matrix
without any problem, we can
create just one common script
that runs our sequential models
and just import and export
the data between them.
And after running all
the models and processes,
and it just gives us
the final solution
of the optimized parameters
and their confidence intervals.
So here for example, we
created a common script
that tells Vensim to
optimize the first model,
then import the value
from the first model
and calculate the W while
you're running the second model.
And after that, just import
the W from the CalcW model
and just do another
optimization to get
the second to do another
optimization on SecondStep
model.
Finally, export the values
to the confidence values
of unknown parameters to
the confidence interval,
and just calculate the
confidence interval.
So using such as system, using
such a common script system,
we can just do one-- just
gives Vensim one common,
and it will just do the whole
process of our series models
one after each other, and
do the whole thing together.
And just gives us the
final parameter's value
and their confidence interval.
So that was it.
Thank you so much for watching.